Por qué fue la muerte de amení la gota
que desbordó el vaso de paciencia de los
iraníes pasaron de pedir el fin de la
represión a pedir el fin del gobierno
bien Creo que hay un cambio de época que
no ha terminado de entender el régimen
de Irán estamos ante una era de
gobernanza interactiva en la que ya es
difícil pensar en manejar bajo los
estatutos del régimen teocrático de los
ellatoras un estado hay una madurez
política natural de la generación última
a nivel global y creo que no ha sabido
leer muy bien esta nueva forma de
reacción política y social que se ha
construido en el imaginario de las
nuevas generaciones iraníes Además de
eso está el efecto de la diáspora que
con esta globalización esta
simultanización de la sociedad global ha
construido una red un entramado entre
quienes Residen como parte de la
diáspora iraní en los Estados Unidos y
quienes Todavía viven en el país de
atolas esta comunicación esta
transferencia cultural permanente y en
tiempo real ha alimentado valores
democráticos muy fuertes
independientemente del régimen rígido
que tienen allá y de sus prohibiciones
con esa medida las expectativas
democráticas han crecido a la par de los
Estados Unidos independientemente de
vivir ellos bajo un régimen teocrático
cerrado
Ahora corre realmente peligro el régimen
de los ayatolacen Irán puede el país
aspirar a un futuro más secular bien las
protestas no van a terminar Porque
además hay una transferencia de
movilización Es decir de toda esa
experiencia viva de lo que son las
luchas por las libertades civiles en el
primer mundo y eso no lo pueden
controlar ni hay manera de filtrarlo
desde el régimen de Irán Hay demasiadas
connotaciones en la transferencia
cultural en la coexistencia
simultaneidad en la infancia política
ideológica de la diáspora americana
iraní como para pensar que esto va a
parar yo pienso que lo que no está
sucediendo y a este punto debería es que
lo que están reclamando varios
ciudadanos iraní americanos ceda Y es
que la administración va a ir en
distinta finalmente política de política
pública y empiece un legado por miles de
ciudadanos americanos iraníes están
sufriendo represión muchos de ellos de
pensión hay tres casos específicos por
los cuales
últimos días en Washington está jugando
fuertemente y es el caso de
los tres americanos esto ya están
detenidos allá viendo reclusión
seguramente van de objeto de
empañamiento ideológica iba a tener
continuidad